you know who said there was no
wrongdoing people who knew anything
about policing you know who said there
was wrongdoing
every single democrat what i'm seeing
right now is the democrats who run
every one of these major american cities
are not keeping you safe they're making
your life worse
the level of civilian understanding of
how policing works is abysmal
truly awful just to take a perfect
example
over the past several nights we've had
these riots in brooklyn center and they
are full-scale riots you have people
attacking police officers you've had
the national guard having fire tear gas
at people you've seen people attempting
to
break in and loot stores it's really
really ugly
it looks like a war zone in parts of
brooklyn center well yesterday the
brooklyn center mayor said
i don't believe officers need to have
weapons when they make arrests
i'm gonna need he's gonna need to show
his work on paper here for me to
understand
what nellie's talking about here i don't
believe that
officers need to necessarily uh
have weapons uh you know
every time they they're they're making a
traffic stop
or or engaged in uh
situations that don't necessarily call
for
uh for weapons we know that there are
other many other jurisdictions or even
around the world where
that is not you know necessarily the
case it's not needed
see one of the things that is very odd
about sort of the leftist worldview with
regard to policing
is the left wants a lot of very
stringent regulations on how you live
your life
and there are lots of regulations on how
cigarettes are sold for example or they
want heavy regulations
on how exactly you're able to operate
your vehicle they want heavy regulations
on virtually every area of life but they
refuse to acknowledge the reality of
regulations
which is that all regulations in the end
are enforced at the point of a
government gun
this is true with regards to your taxes
it is true with regard to environmental
protections
in the end if you resist arrest if you
refuse to obey the law there will be a
government gun at the end of it they
don't like the gun
so at the same time they want to promote
heavy regulations at the same time
they want to ensure that the government
has more power they shy away from the
idea that that power actually
exists so you have this bizarre
situation where the mayor of brooklyn
center
is now saying that if you pull somebody
over for drunk driving for example that
the police officer shouldn't have a
weapon okay well what happens when the
guy pops back in his car and takes off
you're supposed to stand there with
nothing in your hands how exactly is
that supposed to work
and the answer is they don't think about
how this stuff works because they don't
care how this stuff works all of it is
posturing
it is all rooted in a basic
misconception which is that policing
is nice and happy and that everything
works out well
police officers have millions of
interactions with people every single
year
millions something like 4 million
interactions between the police and
civilians every single year
and those interactions are generally not
wonderful because nobody's having a good
day
when they interact with a cop police
officers know this
but again when you have civilians who
don't understand
how any of this works making the rules
and doing so on the basis of bad data
that is a bad thing now you should have
civilian i'm not arguing that the police
should basically just quote unquote
control themselves that the police
should be the only
authority in how they use their force
that of course would be fascistic
you can't have armed wings of the
american government being the only
court of appeal however the sort of
loosening of regulations that you are
seeing by democrats
in terms of how you prosecute officers
the attempt to prevent officers from
doing their jobs at any sort of
expert level understanding on this sort
of stuff is really a problem
and it's going to lead to more death
there's a recent study that came out and
it showed
that in america's major cities the ones
that were that were riven by protests
from 2014 to 2019 ever since the
shooting of michael brown in ferguson
missouri
that the number of police avoidable
deaths according to this study
was something like 300 and the number of
total deaths
that were actually created in other
words there were 300 fewer deaths
because of
interactions between cops and civilians
or cops and suspects
but the number of total deaths in those
cities that were avoidable rose by
something like
6 000 because it turns out when you take
cops off the streets when you tell cops
not to do their job they won't do their
job and when they don't do their job bad
things happen some people on the left
are at least honest enough to go all the
way here
so obviously had rashida talib
suggesting it's time to abolish policing
in the united states overall jason
johnson on msnbc saying the exact same
thing
honestly if this is how democrats want
to play it go for it we'll see if
americans really feel
like they are so safe from their fellow
american that the police can just be
disbanded
i've been saying we need to abolish
american policing as it currently exists
it doesn't work you know the average
homicides that are actually solved by
police departments only about 35
you know the number of rapes and sexual
assaults that are sold by police
departments
you know less than 60 you know the
percentage
likelihood of being shot unarmed as a
black person is like five times as
likely than a white person policing
doesn't
work the way we're doing it right now uh
i have a question what does he think the
level of a homicide
solving uh finding the the actual perp
in a homicide what do you think that
level would be if there were no police
would it be 35 or it would be zero is
the great obstacle
to solving homicides the police being
bad at their jobs or is it that a lot of
people won't testify
and give actual witness evidence with
regard to homicides
getting rid of the police doesn't solve
the problem of homicide it creates more
homicides
if somebody is raped who do you go to in
this particular case
and the notion that black people are
being shot by the police
at five times the rate of white people
is just not true
okay statistically speaking that is not
i'm unaware of any stats that
demonstrate that black people on a per
capita level are being shot at five
times the rate of white people
that that is that is a bizarre again
evidence-free statement so far as i'm
aware if somebody can disabuse me of
that i am happy to take a look at those
stats
in actuality something like 500 white
americans were shot by the cops between
january of 2020 and march of 2021.
okay so i i'm not and the number of
unarmed black men
according to the washington post who are
shot every year by the police
generally less than 30. but this is all
rooted in basic misunderstandings
of how policing works and also
rooted in a certain animus for the
police which results in just
lies to take an example remember that
old jacob lake case
remember that case where a man was
called to a man
arrived at the site of his
ex-girlfriend's house and
uh who who had accused him of of of rape
with his finger
earlier on uh in the in the year i
believe and
she called the police saying this guy is
back at the house and the police arrive
he resists arrest
he has a knife he reaches into the car
they shoot him
remember that joe biden and kamal harris
called that guy and talked about what
rough life
he had and how difficult it was for him
and how terrible the police were
well now it turns out that the police
officer who shot jacob blake last summer
is back on duty
because the kenosha police investigation
found no wrongdoing you know why because
there was no wrongdoing
you know who said there was no
wrongdoing people who knew anything
about policing you know who said there
was wrongdoing
every single democrat everyone i'm
unaware of a democrat who said that
those police officers were entitled to
due process
and that even the tape was not
dispositive with regard to whether the
police officers had done something wrong
didn't matter resulted in riots in
kenosha
you remember this it happened in the
middle of last year not that long ago
you see the same sort of myth making
happening now happening now with regard
to the dante wright case
okay it is this was fairly obviously an
accident
by the police officer who will indeed be
and end up being charged for
manslaughter
a police officer drew a gun instead of a
taser which is an inexcusable mistake
and then shot
dante wright now there are additional
facts about dante wright that we are
learning about that cast some serious
doubt on the
idea that he is some sort of wonderful
person but that is not
really indicative as to the crime
committed
by the officer in question it does
it does really blow up the narrative
that when whenever you have one of these
situations whether it's george floyd
whether it's dante right or whether it's
jacob blake the initial
reaction the media are is always
this person is a wonderful tremendous
human
and all of the police are evil and
terrible two things can be true at once
one the person could be a criminal and
two the police could have done something
wrong
which tends to be more often the case in
these controversial cases but in any
case
that's not even the myth making i'm
talking about the real myth making is
the attempt to rewrite the evidence in
the case
to now suggest that this shooting of
dante wright was not an accident
it was in fact on purpose so for example
you have the the and of dante wright
speaking publicly
and saying this was not an accident it
was outright murder
now we showed you the body cam footage
yesterday the woman literally yells it's
a female officer she literally yells
taser taser taser shoots the guy that
says oh my god i shot him
it's going to be hard to come up with
better evidence of of
accident than that but here is the ant
suggesting that his murder anyway
did y'all not see my little great nephew
did y'all not see that beautiful baby
he is fatherless not over a mistake
[Music]
okay um i'm sorry it was not murder
it was a tragedy it was a horrible
circumstance and the woman is going to
end up
probably copying the manslaughter but
that was not murder
okay and and aoc is saying the same
thing because again the idea is that
evidence is unnecessary in order to
declare that the police are really bad
so aoc
the the incredible brilliant
insightful fresh faced so fresh
so face alexander ocasio-cortez famous
mostly for being very popular on twitter
she tweeted out dante right's killing
was not a random disconnected accident
oh it wasn't really explain it was the
repeated outcome of an indefensible
system that grants impunity for state
violence rewards it with endlessly
growing budgets at the cost of community
investment and targets those who
question that order
okay that is just insane i'm sorry
that's that's crazy
when she says that dante wright's
killing was not a random disconnected
accident which is exactly what it was
that it was the repeated outcome of an
indefensible system that grants impunity
for
this woman's gonna end up on
manslaughter charges rewards it with
endlessly growing budgets
at the cost of community investment i
wasn't aware that when you
actually invest in the police that
doesn't count as a community investment
considering that the
single greatest factor in reducing crime
rates is putting cops on the streets
and targets those who question that
order weird because aoc questions that
order
and i'm not seeing the police pulling
her over and or doing something
terrible to her i'm not seeing that then
she suggested
cameras chokehold bans retraining funds
and similar reform measures do not
ultimately solve what is a systemic
problem so she's saying that you can't
even take
actions that are likely to reduce the
likelihood of bad circumstances
she says the system will find a way
killings happen on camera people are
killed in other ways retraining grows
money
while often substituting for deeper
measures so what exactly is her solution
presumably defund the police and then
you want these people deciding
what is best for for you and your
community
it's pretty incredible stuff speaking of
which the officer
and the uh and the police chief in uh in
brooklyn center have now resigned
so again the notion that the system is
completely it's a complete failure
and that this particular incident is
evidence of the complete failure of the
system
the body cams gave you the evidence the
body cams are what
let you know what happened here the
information was released to the public
doesn't matter the the point here from
the media from the democrats is that the
cops are always bad
the cops have to be stopped the cops are
a rampant fascist force
out of control and the only undergirding
so much of what democrats talk about
cops is this
they have this bifurcated view of cops
on the one hand they will they will pay
homage to them the same way that joe
biden paid homage to a police officer
who was killed at the capitol
yesterday and they'll do so in moving
fashion on the other hand they will
suggest that america's police are
systemically racist
and it all depends on the circumstance
but
in the end can you trust democrats to
keep your city safe i'm wondering
because what i'm seeing right now is the
democrats who
run every one of these major american
cities are not keeping you safe they're
making your life worse
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content